nothing to give us the wall street view
on this obviously the stocks looking
pretty good yeah well just on a stock
movement after the clothes as part of
the announcement the company reaffirmed
their full-year guidance I think that's
part of the reaction but you know I also
think that you know are there are a
number of investors who like your
previous callers think that Twitter can
overhaul its its its user interface to
improve it to make it more engaging to
rejuvenate growth in users to amp the
monetization and we accelerate it and
there's a view that yeah it's time for a
fresh change in leadership we'll see
what the company says on its conference
call in a half an hour I will see how
the stock trades tomorrow morning but
just look it's such a volatile
leadership culture at Twitter you've
been going back to the early days and if
anyone has any one of your listeners has
has read hatching Twitter you can you
can kind of just take away from that
book that you have a history of change
in terms of the leadership and for me
you know I contrast that with something
like Facebook which admittedly is
controlled and closely held by Mark but
you have a very stable leadership and a
very strong and and and well clarified
vision for the future of the company so
you know it remains to be seen whether
or not these management changes will
have more of a detrimental impact on
Twitter over time than a positive one
you know I i have read every word of
that book hatching Twitter by Nick
Bilton George Zachary was quoted in that
book and it reads George like a
telenovela because there is so much
drama I mean is it really like that on
the inside at Twitter isn't a soap opera
it was from my very first experiences
when it was oh do and then it became
Twitter there was always volatility in
the company there was always volatility
between the players in the in the
company but you know I don't see the
maliciousness that make ascribed to the
players there was no behavior where she
was always gunning to
come back a CEO because that's I think
he probably had a desire to but I don't
think there was like the evilness that
Nick pointed out I think there was some
passive aggressive behavior but I also
think it was a bunch of people who
didn't communicate well together which
is so they found a method to communicate
which was an indirect method which by
the way is also Twitter I mean they
created a product which is identical to
their method of communication which is
indirect Tim you know from your
experience at Yahoo another company that
has struggled how difficult is it going
to be to change that culture from the
inside out it's enormously difficult
it's enormously difficult if you if you
choose an internal candidate and it's
enormously difficult if you choose an
external candidate there there's really
i said earlier communication is
absolutely the key and just keep at it
but you need to have something to say as
well they have to first decide really
what they're doing what they want to be
and then the messaging can flow but this
is the changing any culture is tough and
such a high-profile fishbowl if you will
as Twitter and as yahoo was it is you
know multiply it times 100,000